what do you make of what's going to
happen over the next 48 hours and then
tell us what you think happens Monday
well this reminds me a lot of what
happens in Northern Rock when I was at
the bank of england and the weekend was
crucial because all the discussions was
actually about the fact that you really
worry about what happens when the banks
open on monday if you don't do something
verra Farkas has actually been talking I
see on the Bloomberg talking to the
central bank saying you're saying
there's a little quiddity crisis well in
essence all the things you've talked
about suggest to anybody sitting in
Greece there is a fundamental crisis and
they probably should get their money out
it's been coming out during the week so
this looks to me like first of all more
palliatives the worry is Monday but I
think fundamentally what we haven't
heard is a long-term fix this is just a
short-term band-aid if you like where is
the long-term fix I wrote on my pad
there is no such thing as an
expansionary fiscal contraction which
means more austerity means further down
so I'm really I just don't think this is
in any sense of fix and either either
something what happened by Monday or
it'll happen at a future Monday in the
next two or three months so in the
meantime Danny what would force the
government the Greek government to
impose bank controls or capital controls
or capital management as it's being
euphemistically called now well
obviously money going out of the banks
and it's been doing that over the last
few days but if you were to listen to
what happened today presumably you would
think if you had money in a Greek bank
it was time to get it out of that Bank
so that's the worry and Vera [ __ ]
clearly understands that but I think we
should just go back and think what here
is actually going to do something to
help Greece raise its GDP and lower its
unemployment rate and I don't see
anything Danny Blanchflower who are the
key players in this besides the Greek
Prime Minister and the greek Finance
Minister well obviously the german
finance minister in
and Angela Merkel is clearly important
figures here and the rest but they're
the thing they're really the two main
ones but I keep saying and I've said on
this program a number of times Greece
actually does have a bargaining chip I
haven't heard people say that France and
Germany actually have 160 billion euros
that the Greeks owns them both them
Greece has been in default half of the
last 250 years if they default that's a
huge amount of money it's a political
disaster but it also has an impact on
the other members of the of the
community of the eurozone so I do think
that the whole thing has contagion in
the air we don't know what the long run
effects are of the UK and even in the US
and that's the fear that this generates
a globe another global financial crisis
and in some sense that's the card that
tsipras is playing as well as trying to
play he's in Russia today talking to
Putin this is this is your high stakes
poker I guess you'd call it high stakes
poker do you see anything coming out of
that the discussions between Greece and
Russia where Russia can come in and be a
white knight what about being a right a
white knight I mean obviously there's an
issue down the road which is that all EU
members are going to vote on the renewal
of sanctions in a few months time and
what and what one country can stop it so
obviously that's part of it I'm
apparently Greece and Russia signed a
deal today with a pipeline going through
it I mean I think this is political
positioning but I keep going back to
well where's the long run fix here what
suddenly gets the Greek economy to
expand and I think that tsipras is point
and Vera Farkas this point to get the
list that's to understand output is down
twenty-five percent since 2010 and if
the measures imposed by that they eat by
don't bother but but by the troika are
implemented I just see unemployment
rising again and output falling further
and eventually the people will speak and
the young people have been speaking over
the last few days so this is crisis upon
crisis temporary fix but there's no
evidence here whatsoever of a long-run
fixed and the fundamental thing is that
austerity
hasn't worked in Greece it hasn't worked
anywhere else and so he that's the
impasse we have